One day, little Eddie the Endorphin went to
play in the park with his receptors.
But when he got there, he ran into the obnoxious
opioids - Hector the Heroin, Curtis the codeine,
and Fred the Fentanyl.
The obnoxious opioids punched Eddie in the
face and Eddie tried to fight back, but it
was too late, the obnoxious opioids had already
taken Eddie’s toy receptors and he was left
on the ground unable to fight back.
Opioids are substances that inhibit the transmission
of pain information to the brain by turning
on the brain’s reward system.
Endogenous opioids, such as endorphins and
enkephalins, are naturally produced by our
body to help modulate motivation, emotions,
food intake, and our response to pain.
Like endogenous opioids, opioid drugs stimulate
opiate receptors at the synaptic membrane
and in some places, inside the nerve cells.
Opioid receptors are part of a family of membrane
receptors called G-protein coupled receptors,
or GPCRs.
Ligands binding to GPCRs induces the phosphorylation
of intracellular GDP to GTP, this causes the
migration of a G-Protein to a membrane kinase
which cleaves a phosphate group off GTP, converting
it back to GDP, and using the extra phosphate
to initiate a cellular response.
In opioid receptors, the cellular response
results in the opening of potassium channels
in neurons.
This causes hyperpolarization, which limits
input from nerve fibers that control responses
from pain receptors.
Once opioids cross the blood-brain barrier,
they bind to opioid receptors that are found
throughout the central and peripheral central
nervous system.
This modulates the activity of the brain stem
which causes slowed breathing that results
in sleepiness and increased relaxation.
Addiction and dependence can cause someone
to overdose resulting in forgetting to breathe
and eventually dying.
Naloxone is a medication used to reverse an
opioid overdose.
It can be administered in a nasal spray or
via an injection up to 40 minutes after opioid
consumption.
Naloxone separates the opioid molecules from
the receptors and binds to the receptors itself.
In the future, improving access to treatment
and recovery services, and supporting research
on the role of opioids in pain and addiction
will be key in fighting the opioid crisis.